[Music]
you watch chair what's his name Jerome
Jerome Jerry Jerry he's so great
favorite I'm trying to get Monica the
coach on the pod yes she's the Knicks
Amite Nick Saban of women I don't know
what that means who's Nick's Amen Nick
Saban my favor oh wow my screen saver
right now is Monica from cheer i should
have jerry on there I know I know I
could shove Jerry on here but I mean I
think I should he's doing so much press
right now he blew so positive for him
when he's cheated fat I mean when he
stood up I was like house no one gonna
acknowledge his cheat it's so outrageous
he's so positive yeah I love him so much
and when he I'm the first time he didn't
make mat and then the second time he
didn't make mad but he's so positive
fact that he didn't make mat you make it
either time and you're heartbroken for
and they stays at you I'm like goddamn I
ain't that guy I've been talking shit
out of that gym I love him so my love's
Jerry you know I even looked in buying
Navarro t-shirts
I just bought a Navarro I want the shirt
on stage I want this shirt I bet we can
get shirts made can't we Benton hates my
love of cheer you don't like Jerry
whatever you would like
I watched it but I mean I I grew up
around very normal people so normal
people don't impress me the way they do
with me oh you mean because he's nice
and Texas is what you like him no I like
Jerry yeah who's great he'd stay with my
aunt's friend for a long time he has
been seen as an interesting theory on
shear that what did you say it's like
drag in the sonic drag in the middle of
America
that's like cheer is yeah it's yeah
there's no straight guys on the team is
there
I mean um boys and I don't know them
over the zoom there's not they didn't
highlight any of them I don't think they
have a friend who was a male children
and he's straight as you know yeah so
you know Chappelle they see you know -
Chappelle atomic he's great he checked
out
Louisville yeah yeah who's like I'll do
this fantastic I got so many girls I'm
blo I'm like yeah yeah I think you're
the exception I just love it because it
is so hard
what they're doing is incredible right I
think so I think were they the the guy
who made it he also made last chance to
you did you watch that so that's basic
air but football and it's with all these
you know college d1 rejects who they're
so talented they should be in the NFL
but they fucked up small school in
Kansas but they're the JUCO football
like Navarro is of cheerleading it's in
the middle of nowhere but the the last
chance last jet you'll love it it's the
best the coach is this white guy who's
born in Compton so he relates the black
guys yeah so it's it's so entertaining
it's more entertaining than chair and
you in the same director who did both
but he goes oh after I did chair you
know I'd say cheerleading's that it's
the toughest boat sport in the world
take it easy - but take it easy I mean
hey take it easy would you let your kids
play football if they're really talented
yes if they're just running your mill
fucking how do they get talented if they
don't you know you know how yo know how
my coaches knew my parents knew because
when you're around other six-year-olds
and you hand me a football and no one
can touch me I'm the fast son that feels
like I don't might have something here
but if he's just a guy and like read a
book what has are you gonna throw the
football around yes like my fire my for
my four year old super athletic like you
did like you put a ball out and it came
on he's just like athletically he's
gifted but again if it's if he's if you
don't have a real gift at it you're not
playing football man but you so I'll
know I'm telling you I know it sounds
fucked up but I'll know but I also you
know my biggest problem is why I have
insecurities now about
my intelligence is like when I was
playing football especially at CU you
major in football but we my my my major
did not matter like they gave me the
easiest classes and I would go into my
advisor but I don't need the class with
the other guys like I I don't have to
show up for class on making these these
tests like I'm telling you give me real
classes man yeah she's like this is the
schedule that works with the practice
and so I just remember that I know
yeah I'm really kid you're saying you
don't want your kid going to college and
not getting really I don't want to I
don't want a major in football if you're
gonna well it just depends it's tough
it's it's so tough do you think
footballs gonna stay around in our
lifetime yes never go away never too big
it's America's sport what happens if but
I saw I think CT you're like yeah no
shit dude you have CT CTS also you think
we have CT well yeah it made me funny no
I'm just kidding I think I think CT is
over it like yeah we have the studies
now and people have to pass wait to
realize what's happening and you know
I'll see Hernandez was terrible but also
those studies are being so exaggerated
and it's you know most guys are okay the
percentage of football players playing
all their lives and played for 10 15
most of our okay thriving Tony Romo you
know is one of the best comte's in the
world I mean concussions he had Troy
Aikman's one of the best lips in general
those guys were okay
there's the exception with Junior Seau
and in Hernandez but in general
footballs okay and Aaron Hernandez just
have more than the average percent or
more yeah he had the worst they've ever
seen in that age group I think he was 24
and he had the worst CT they've ever
seen at a certain position that's the
most common that happens in uh no I mean
he played tough you know I played tight
in so he's getting hit a lot but the
worst thing you've ever seen but I do
think like everyone's focused so much on
CT and football and how bad is free but
bring so many people so much to joy and
a lot of people that's how they get out
of whatever situation they're in it it
does great things but those studies when
you looking at a lot of those studies
are over exaggerated but isn't also
concussions are under recorded also like
it's only recorded if you actually go
out like a lot of guys get concussions
and they just we're sure the sorts
small concussions but in general the the
general percentage of guys that play
football are just fine hmm just fine
never thought about that and what
absolutely gonna do yeah what its gonna
do yeah and if you asked all those
football players specially let's play in
the Super Bowl on Sunday hey man
you probably have CT when you're 70 yeah
okay fine I'll have something when I'm
sad what else am I gonna yeah yeah yeah
what else win do you think that college
players should get paid yes that's the
biggest crook the biggest scam in any
institution it's so fucked up it's so
fucked up it's form of slavery and then
they go oh well we're giving education
no you're not I was there man yeah
yeah I was it's an awful education no
it's not real you're passing the classes
they're selling jerseys and they're
making millions and millions of dollars
off that kid when Tim Tebow is playing
for Florida in then when asked champ
chip he had the number one selling
jersey in the world over Michael Jordan
over Kobe over Tom Brady the number one
selling jersey in the world how much
money received for it zero that's not so
fucked up basketball - yes why don't
they pay them it's just a scam
eventually they well once comes around
to it but it's just a matter of time
it's just so fucked up because you look
at a guy like - who's a the court for
Alabama he supposed to be the first pick
in the draft and he got hurt roll tide
roll tide what's up girl
he's Nick Saban he's the best college
coach there's so but that kid - uh was
supposed to be the number one pick in
the draft he got his last game you got
hurt blew out his hip so he's fucked so
let's say can't play anymore he want you
want a national champ sold all these
jerseys you know what happens to him I
don't know working out fucking Blue
Bottle asking me question
it's such a bummer Wow and who changes
that who has to do something I don't
know the institutions you know college
is such a heavy institution and - good
luck man I don't know and then they
won't like it's their turn to sports but
but they won't like kids like like your
basketball you have to go to college for
a year you can't go straight to the NBA
what do you think that is why because
they have to make money of that player
before he goes the NBA
Wow all the guys in the room are nodding
in NFL in NFL if you play college
football let's say you graduate high
school it's a very rare but let's say
you graduate high school and you're
ready for the NFL you me the first pick
nope
you uh play two years of college
football why do you think that is so the
institution can make all that money and
then you can go it's so fun this is so
fucked up how come the cheerleaders
don't make any money this is
cheerleaders no one's paying money to
watch cheerleaders yeah that's when
they're like oh it's you know football
you know like it should be if you have
women make this man make this like yeah
no I'm not doing that but I don't want
to do this I doc you don't wanna do it
I'm not gonna do that with you but
here's what I will say I'm gonna play
devil's advocate because that's what
comedians do we say things we don't
always mean don't bring it so n be a
basketball okay they make like $15 an
hour
they make $100 a game basically okay
okay and they're not allowed to date two
players okay if they're gonna make $100
an hour they should be able to date
players in my opinion yeah they can date
the players they don't want it not
allowed or the maybe that's NF but y'all
know you're not allowed to date any of
them but it always happens like they
always date men yeah but what's the
point if she what's the point of doing
it unless you're gonna get a I agree you
know I mean I agree I thought you're
gonna offend paying the cheerleaders
more I mean I don't I don't you could
probably pay the mortgage I mean is that
even minimum wage I don't know how many
hours of game I don't know I don't know
how many hours they practice yeah I
think they make less than minimum wage
and the benefit is maybe I'm gonna meet
this guy or maybe you know and yeah
because votes no one's getting famous
off of it yeah me Paula Abdul was a
Laker but that's right but notes gets it
I do think cheerleaders should get paid
more because they asked them to do
appearances for free they need some sort
of use I know nothing about this but oh
you're right they need some sort of yeah
that's what they need some sort of Union
yes they've no leverage though because
they anyone else would do in a heartbeat
yeah because the here's if and if you're
a NFL owner and those cheerleaders like
hey we want more you owe us this you
know we want more picket signs if I'm an
owner I'm like
yes can go away let's see what happens
ticket sales let's see if nothing oh no
nothing nothing but not offence but not
not a thing nothing but not a damn thing
no no it's cool yeah did you enjoy but
no he gives a flying fuck that was my
prom with that cheer show I'm watching
those kids going they're putting all
this especially the the one with the
fucking helicopter parents
I'm watching her what do you want for
which one I need what do you want for I
want Gaby's parents to back the fuck up
yeah and let her live a little also my
dad making calls and get me a bikini
line no you don't I do I you say that I
think that her dad is getting way too
much shit he does see what he seems
super creepy I think so too but like she
was a shower walk to like how's that ass
good Oh Papa I felt like everybody on
the show seemed really Hollow except for
Jerry they were all very sad to me hold
up how about how about the emo Jake well
get to her her name that does not end
well lies no it's not what is her name
Nemo chick I was just checking I was
just texting with her Lexi you were
texting about anything about her Lexi
will get to Lexi in a second but Gabby
let's slow down with Gabby I can't
remember what the argument was but I got
these parents yes I don't I think there
is a weird war on men where no man can
do anything right
if the dad was absent we would say he
was an asshole if he was taking her to
practice we'd say he was a pervert if
he's helping her build her business he's
two hands on what version of Gabby's dad
would we not cribbens done right the red
flag of it for me the first red flag was
whenever there had an interview with it
it hasn't - dude how you his daughter I
don't you but him and his wife they're
talking and his wife's like oh that's
not he said will you just tell the story
go ahead to the story I saw the story go
right ahead
a moment like that Benton you've never
been pissed off in an argument I'm just
saying to your wife
get the fuck out of here both no hold on
no here's the problem wit here's the
problem here's the problem is when they
go man.you you're doing this schedule
during this schedule we get done you
know I know you want to rest but you got
to do this you can see like dude I don't
want to do you gonna tell she's like I'm
fucking over this man like you're not to
go here do this through this I'm like
you gotta let that girl be a fucking
girl man because when this ends it's not
pretty
she put on fucking a hundred pounds to
mount a thousand pounds sister new show
on TLC and that's how it ends she's new
back flips and she wanna be a champion
or not she was made what I'm playing
devil's advocate maybe she was she's
like well I want to win I want this I
want this bikini line and then she's
sitting around on her phone being a brat
and not taking care of her cell phone
he's like well do you want to do this
thing or not I put a bunch of time into
your career I've raised you I put all my
savings into these fucking sequin
uniforms now hold on hold on here's the
problem those parents career is their
dog he's running the business I know how
documentaries work I know how TV shows
work I know that had they manipulate
people to look certain ways Lexi's story
she already came out and said that the
the John's Lexi Lexi's the blonde emo
girl her raving that was before Daytona
Beach and they put at the end to make it
look like she unceremoniously was
removed and then was just like vaping at
raves that was she not removed from the
team she was but then she got back and
then did Daytona Daytona was before that
they could change what she did get
kicked up you late what is she on the
team
she's on the team back at the end yeah
and went okay so she's good now the rave
was not at the end they switched it so
they do a lot of it yeah they do a lot
of manipulate
maybe maybe but here's the thing
everybody in every documentary says the
same thing in Hernandez wife is like he
was not gay he was not a murderer
the guy I'm fucking making a murderer
listen Brandon - he's actually very
smart the Michael Jackson guys are like
they all say the same thing I am not
buying it yeah I just I just think and I
know I'm playing devil's advocate a
little bit because you know I'm the
first person to be like a dad's not but
handlings right I just I don't know I I
just think there's something to be said
for having expectations for your kids
and my dad fuckin rode me so that's such
a gross thing to say but that's a sink
bro be so hard about whether it's so
hard with studies and I'm so grateful
that he did and I hate it at the time
but my work ethic is all from my dad for
sure if my dad talked about something
different I agree that me too if my dad
was in a documentary about me everyone
would think he was a fucking asshole yes
so grateful that my dad had such high
expectations for me and worked me so
hard and if my dad your dad son Whitney
Cummings bikinis they're one pieces you
dad managing your tour and your merch
not and making sure you shopping
Cleveland works and then when you go pop
I need a break on I know it's not the
time cap Eliza
fine fucking Jessica Simpson's parents
did it Miley Cyrus's parents did it
Katherine Heigl's mom did it
hold on what go through those three
examples let's talk about all three of
them happy to a Tharin Heigl how bad is
the house in Utah doing great works
whenever she wants yes she set a crazy
thing on ellen fein not a lot of people
like her but those pills are getting
paid anyone would fucking take her
career it's what she said I don't shows
so not her car after the Judd Apatow
stuff after the yep jus a show okay so
she say you what work you say USA they
say most watch net net much most watch
network bullsh on TV network that's not
true USA there's no way that's true
let's watch that work you have a show on
there so what's going on there all right
see now you're a now this is fucking
this is this shit I do know shit about I
do I say it's the most-watched Network
let's watch what show with a blue-collar
factor more than ABC NBC American Idol
bachelor/bachelorette most-watched cable
network oh you're changing the to Burn
Notice change top network I'm googling
this right now okay so Katherine Heigl
you lost
household name movie star Katherine
you're so loose with the movie start
with me star right now she fucking
stepped in some shit but her bitch she
sure did everything she needed to do
sure her mom showed up okay
her mom handled shit and later rich and
the house in Utah house Miley Cyrus's
mental game she's self destructed on her
own she was a child star that's
different from like eight Gabby's not
job he's a child star Gabby got famous
at eight doing YouTube YouTube video is
that the pop would filming doing this
confusing keeping your kid accountable
and not giving up he's a lot of these
who is such a I don't know I just think
Oh who's your third one I think parent
Jessica Simpson who is of a great career
billion dollars billion dollars come on
the show anytime Jesse can't add has a
billion dollars I love justice she's
fantastic she was my favorite out of
like those girls was like Christina
Aguilera Britney Spears or Jessica
Simpson oh yeah Ana just Simpson
calendar I think we're too hard on stage
parents I think you're confused that's
not hunting either you're confused on
discipline and stage pins but also
there's a if you're getting followed by
a camera crew for four months you're
gonna say something dumb you're gonna do
something dumb you're gonna lose your
temper but if that dad acted that way
towards you how would you handle it
might do that by dad did act like that
towards me my dad used to fucking make
me stay up till 2:00 in the morning and
quiz me with vocab words when I already
taken the test so look how you turned
out and look
now land cartons it's no problem
it's a tricky line man I just think I
and look here's the other thing my mom
is from Texas and I know that is a
mentality that is just a very specific
look we play to win we're not here to
get second place take it easy I'm just
saying bricky Bobby take it easy
that's just like a mentality that I
value that mentality and I've discipline
I do too but not but back but here's
what I don't like it's also I don't know
this guy and I know a lot of people
think that he's trash but oh no I don't
think he's a bad person I don't either
I don't know do you not I mean but I if
she goes it's my dream in life to be a
famous successful cheerleader that she
said that to her I did you hear that I
didn't hear that from her mouth
I heard her putting myself on YouTube at
eight years old yeah yeah how to edit
and do all the YouTube channel the dad
did you don't know that you don't know
that kids do kids are very nice Monica
and he's not Monica is the better
example of I think you saw a sliver of
who he is and we were of course I did we
will never know who he is and I'm not
like going on about here's what I just
don't like that when a parents no one
was going after the mom by the way
people only go after the dad because
people wanna go like oh he's creeping I
went after the mom there are guys who
have daughters who are in gymnastics
that aren't trying to fuck their own
daughters like why like why do we go
there I never thought that both the
parents were getting so many comments
really i sat there overbearing but in
order to be the best of what you do you
have to have overbearing parents and
coaches and excellence doesn't coaches
coaches yes lackadaisical sloppy as
parents I hear you and here's what say
if your kid is in that kind of a
competitive lifestyle its 24/7 this
father has given up his life to drive
her to because he had nothing else to do
he needed to make money off his daughter
at eight years old on YouTube how much
money was he making offer I'd like to
know this I don't know he looked like he
had a stack of fucking documents he was
making calls to people for some clinic a
hundred excuse me a hundred dollars a
ticket this guy's working harder than
buddy what blood sweat tears trying to
make his daughter's dreams come true it
brings a tear of my eye
how much he gives a shit and she doesn't
even care I'll tell you what that the
emo chick wishes she had a dad like that
she's at Lala they're fucking shows up
and we're yelling at him you know I'm
not yelling at alights was she backed up
a little let her be a kid but he's not a
documentary and they're like we're here
to see how you parent and he's alright I
got a really look like I'm doing shit
like yeah baby he was probably trying to
impress the camera people maybe what
else should you watch thousand-pound
sisters no I know you love that so good
what does that mean I don't know what
that I didn't like the newest episode
though I felt it was over it was over
produced they forced the connector
attitudes though they're out fun hounds
thousand-pound sisters one six hundred
ones four hundred their fights they're
so funny there's their youtube stars
that's a loose term their YouTube stars
and they do like you know funny videos
and just they're really funny they're
outgoing they're obviously 400 pounds
one six hundred pounds but you just love
them
yeah like for them is that isn't that
unhealthy I mean are they okay that's
the point of show they're no they're not
okay once 600 once 400 that's what makes
the show fun well why would you want to
watch that I mean it because you root
know you root for him okay and the ones
gonna shit together yeah if maybe if
they had a dad who fucking got him in
line they have terrible pain they'd be
in shape and maybe that's why they
gained weight yeah that's exactly I
think you owe their parents on the show
too
the mom was there but a shit I don't
know how well you can't deal with people
that illegal for your child to be 600
pounds well they're adults now they're
not like kid kids I'd say me too when
they're that big I don't know how do you
even move around that's like Gilbert
great remember that's exactly what is
one needs a walker one came and walk the
other ones like getting fit a lot of fun
got approved for surgery the other
didn't a lot of times that um is from
trauma yeah you get that big because you
had some oh that's cool assault as a
child or something and you make yourself
big and keep weight on to protect
yourself from some kind of abuse
yeah you don't get that big without some
kind that's fascinating right yeah you
root for him I hope it works out what
works out of they try knee in shape yeah
one shapes all relative to training
some sort of shape the Sun again Gabi's
dad
yeah he'll turn you out okay yeah the
real hero of Cheers Morgan which one did
it all alone I love Molly - my favorite
shut up - Morgan
such a nice person and did yachts one to
hug she's got on scene and I was like
you you do worked so hard the underdog
she was the Rudy do I mean the real
heroes are the ones with concussions
that just got dragged off the last three
episodes like what happened to her I was
so nervous when they went home boy blew
his ankle out and they had to redo the
whole thing I was no I know I've seen
all of it I'm trying to remember at the
very end when they're in Daytona state
oh boy literally blows out loud to read
you have to redo it I was like oh dear
God please make this happen and the fact
that they were doing all coverage from
cell phones because they couldn't
actually get access to that to shoot it
I loved that
oh you mean wrongness I mean I just
think so much more kind of a stress oval
yeah I was so stressed I wonder I really
do wonder if that is true or if the
documentary filmmakers just did that
because they knew it would be more
cinematic intense true in fact that they
couldn't get actual access you know I
didn't realize how big of a deal I mean
I usually I've spent so much time in
Texas I didn't realize how high the
stakes are
oh man and I'm fascinated by the fact
that their two rivals are like in the
same town basically yeah I the end when
they show the emo girl just crying
staring out to the ocean see xox it's
all downhill from here
no way I talked about this with a friend
of mine on Tex last night she's actually
a good artist her art is very good yeah
hi peace no okay I said you good I will
and I will and I will buy a Gabby bikini
and I bought my Navarro cheer hat I
wanted to buy a shirt you should make
them they don't have a shirt from on
Etsy can we make Navarro cheer sure it's
just red bubble you're just stealing
merge because is that legal
oh I don't think Navarro is gonna care I
think there's stoked for any of the
publicity
look at this cuz I got this hat this
nabarro cheer hat you don't like it you
don't like it
I'd like the real legit Navarro chair
huh oh it's time to get the website yeah
I could have made that color merged Oh
me at the mall kiosk the cellphone so
bad do not wear that around the worst